- Oh, my Gosh.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] I need to talk about your hair,
all the whole show.
I love your hair.
- Please, I'm so down.
- [Kelly] I love-
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Do you love it?
- You know, I really do.
It's such a change
and it was-
- [Kelly] You have like
the perfect face for it.
Like the perfect all
structure, everything.
- That's one thing that my whole
family said, they were like
it like makes you see your face more.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it definitely was an adjustment.
However, showering is the best thing ever.
It's so nice.
- I have had short hair before like that,
and I was like it felt so light.
- [JoJo] It's so nice.
- You're just like, oh
my God and then it dries.
And it's just like, whatever.
- It's the best.
I went into my mom's room the first day
that I got it done
and I go into her room and I'm like,
you know, thinking, I'm all cool
and I was like,
hey mom guess how long it
took for me to dry my hair?
She's like, shut up.
I was like 30 seconds,
I timed it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [JoJo] And she was like,
oh my God I hate you.
- [Kelly] I love it though.
How it is in the back.
It's such a rag cut.
- Thank you.
- I'm into it.
Okay meet Angela, sorry,
meet Jenna, I'm sorry.
- [Angela] Hi.
- [Jenna] Hi hello, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Angela and I know each other.
- We we're at a very fun Christmas party.
Like where the white elephant gift
you know where it gets rowdy.
- [JoJo] Yes.
- Yeah, it was fun.
- It gets rowdy, I love you.
- [JoJo] It gets rowdy.
- It gets crazy.
My best friend is so jealous that I'm here
with you guys today.
- [Angela] Really?
- [Kelly] Rub it in.
- Oh my God.
- We'll do a video.
- We have to.
- Okay.
- You're meeting, you're meeting Pam
from The Office.
- I just cannot not stop
looking at your hair.
- Thank you.
- I cannot stop looking
even from the side.
It's so cool.
You have to do like some
kind of profile rag shot.
Anyway.
- Thank you.
- You just wrapped your
first tour since coming out.
So how is this different?
Did you feel like, I don't know.
More comfortable, more at
ease, like more yourself.
- Okay, so it's kind of funny.
There's this.
Before I came out, you know,
I had this section in my show
I started this show before I came out
and there's this there was a
part, it called sporty land
and sporty land was
everybody's least favorite.
Yeah, because it was just
like, we had like candy land
and then we had like
Bobo land and then we had
like sporty land and it was like baseball.
That's sporty land actually.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and, and everyone
didn't like it because you know
the colors were just like a
little, not pink and purple.
Like it just was a full, different vibe.
But then this round of tour,
you know, since coming out
and like not to be a stereotypical,
but like it's a thing
that lesbians play softball.
Like it's just a thing.
And so to have-
- Oh my God!
- [JoJo] It's a thing.
- And straight women, but yes-
- It's just well-
- And straight women,
I know straight women that play softball.
- I have played co-ed softball,
the one where you have the
pony keg at second base.
- [Angela] Yeah.
- Did you say a pony keg at second base?
- [Jenna] She did.
- I want to go to that softball game.
- It's so great.
Okay.
- But so it was like
everyone now, like had this
like we were like, you know
we had our baseball bats
and it like was sporty land.
It was like, the gay land.
- [Kelly] oh my Gosh, I love you so much.
- And it ended in everyone's favorite
but it was so nice to be like just free.
Like it just like people
would bring pride flags.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [JoJo] It was just like so cool.
- So wait, now you're a judge
on So You Think You Can Dance.
- Yes.
- So you were a fan of this show
when you were younger-
- [JoJo] Yes.
- And now you're on it.
Is that awesome?
- It's so unreal.
- [Kelly] Full circle.
- I mean growing up,
like in the dance world.
It, it, I was surrounded by,
So You Think You Can Dance.
Yeah I went to, this was the
season five tour, I believe.
So, I mean, I've been
around the show for forever
and now to be a part
of it's comeback in this
capacity is just unreal.
- That's so cool.
- [JoJo] Thank you.
- Dancing feels so good.
Do y'all love dancing?
- [JoJo] Oh my God!
- Mmh.
- Like you answer in unison all the time.
It's amazing.
I love it though.
It feels so good.
My kids, we have dance
parties all the time.
It just feels good.
- It just, it's fun because
I left the dance world
for a long time.
And then I finally got
back in it when I did
Dancing With the Stars
and it just like, felt so good to do that.
And then actually like regain some dance
in my life and then now to be a part of
So You Think it's just, it's unreal.
- I love that for you.
I love the full circle moment.
So what perspective do you think you bring
as a judge for all of them?
- You know, it's interesting.
So, so my, my two co
judges with me are tWitch,
who's amazing-
- [Kelly] That's tWitch.
- And then Matthew Morrison,
and they're both like
literally my brothers now
and, you know, tWitch comes from the
the hip hop, the street background.
Matthew comes from the musical
theater Broadway background.
And I come from like the
technical dance background.
- Okay.
- And so, you know, being,
being honest on somebody
and being hard on somebody,
if they can be, you know,
better in that capacity.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's a different story
than just being straight up harsh.
- You know who's good at that?
John, John Legend.
He's so good at that.
After he gets to talk,
I'm like, how did you-
- Figure out how to say that.
- How did you do that?
I was like, yeah.
I was like, 'cause it wasn't great
And you did it all the, you worded it.
It was like perfectly executed dismount.
I was like, what?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Well, before we go to break
tell us quickly about your foundation.
This is awesome.
- Thank you.
So I created the JoJo Siwa
Childhood Cancer Foundation.
- [Kelly] So cool.
- And it started, you know
I've done a lot of Make
Wishes in my life and
and different types of
organizations similar.
And there's a lot of kids that
go through cancer and, and
and something else for
me is like, you know
people who have cancer
also just have kids.
You know what I mean?
And so there is, there's a lot
of people who can be affected
in so many different ways by cancer.
- I think cancer affects
everyone in some sense.
- [JoJo] In some way.
- Friend's family and loved one, yeah.
- Yeah and if you're, if you're a kid
with cancer or if you're a kid
and your mom has cancer,
you know what I mean?
Like it, it's hard either way.
So I created the JoJo Siwa
Childhood Cancer Foundation and-
- That's awesome.
- And it's been so amazing.
And we have been able to
do so many great things
and I'm so excited.
There's so many more great things.
I say I wanna make kids lives
better with this foundation.
You know, I wanna give
kids the trip to Disney
that they've always wanted.
I wanna give kids, you know,
hospital room, a makeover.
I wanna build a JoJo Siwa playroom
in the Orange County Children's Hospital.
You know, I wanna, I just wanna
I wanna make kids' lives better.
Give 'em something a smile about it.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [JoJo] Thank you.
- [Kelly] And, and hope like,
you know, some kinda hope.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] And happiness.